ron desantis running for governor in
florida just ran a political ad that is
getting a ton
of excellent reaction not only from
conservatives but even some liberals are
admitting this is a good ad
ladies and gentlemen
governor ron desantis
today we deliver for the people of
florida yet again
we saved our jobs
and kept us going they tried to shut us
down
and you saved our business thousand
dollar bonuses you had our backs and
honored our service you led by facts not
fear and you let us decide you let me go
to school you gave me a voice you put us
first and didn't let them keep us apart
you let us learn
you let us compete all of us
[Music]
you protected our right to worship
together in person
and you raised our pay you protected our
waters and kept florida beautiful when
they attacked you you didn't cave you
stood strong for florida thank you thank
you thank you governor gracia de santis
thank you thank you thank you thank you
governor desantis
a good ad it's a good ad it's almost
like five to ten percent too much and i
know
one the only slightly negative reaction
i had when watching it was that the guy
in front of the church who said you let
us keep worshiping and in person and
it's it's nothing about desantis i just
thought oh my gosh is this how far we've
fallen as a country
that we need to run ads saying thank you
thank you for letting me go to church
is that could you imagine the founding
fathers rolling over in their graves
that that's where we're at right now
the great conservative accomplishment is
hey
you let us still show up to church on
sundays without too much harassment
and it is an accomplishment it actually
was a major accomplishment from ron
desantis because so many other people
squished on it
this is a good ad
why is this ad so good
because the ad is all about
well it represents people from all walks
of life all in florida not in an
officious kind of identity politics way
not in a you know i'm the black i'm the
black latino lesbian well i'm the you
know uh quadriplegic
hispanic transsexual pansexual and i'm
the representative of this group no the
groups that are being represented are
our teachers our first responders
our
parents are business owners all right
it's it's much much broader than just
the kind of racial or sexual identity
politics but the real strength of the ad
is
the ad is all about hey you did this
you did this you did that you did this
you did that
it's all
actual accomplishments i was up visiting
my grandmother over the weekend
and she just had the tv on kind of in
the background we weren't really
watching it but it was just kind of on
and i don't have tv i don't have cable i
don't watch the commercials that run on
tv ordinarily and so i see this ad and
it must have run
just in the day and a half i was there
it must have run two dozen times and it
was an ad about
the democrats have passed the inflation
reduction act which will lower costs
which will reduce the energy prices
which will save you money which will
restore our economy which will will will
will will
obviously won't do any of that
the democrats outside of political ads
that are geared toward
specific voting demographics they don't
even really call it the inflation law
anymore
they call it the climate law because the
inflation reduction act
study after study showed isn't actually
going to lower inflation it actually
probably will increase inflation
what'll it do well it'll protect the
environment now or it'll do all these
other nonsense things
so the democrats all they have to run on
is hey things will get better they'll
get better don't worry trust us i know
things got worse when we were ruling but
it's they're going to get better and ron
desantis can point to actual
accomplishments and say things did get
better i'm not telling you they're going
to get better in some indefinite future
they did get better i did things
that's a much more effective
strategy moving into midterm elections
the democrats are really struggling the
best candidate that the democrats are
running this cycle
the number one best candidate is running
for senate in pennsylvania and he's
doing a pretty good job against dr oz
the guy's name is john fetterman and
he's running as a blue collar working
class democrat and it's a total bogus
identity the man's never worked an
honest job in his life and he got paid
50 grand a year in in
a an allowance from his parents to
subsidize his lifestyle
he isn't actually you know the guy that
he presents himself to be but even
beyond that john fetterman's in terrible
health he had a stroke on the campaign
trail he's never answered questions
about his health he he refuses to debate
dr oz he he he can barely get out a few
minutes of speaking
while he hits the various campaign stops
i'm honored to be standing in the shadow
of your murders at your amazing
building
do you think of the 10 homes dr oz have
has a union hall
across their home
if you
say
you think the word
of
s
deal worker
what words come to your mind if you say
steel workers of all the words that
bring to your mind when you hear the
word steel workers
does the word predicate come to your
mind
that's not a word that's going to come
to my mind critique
is wrong with demanding for
an easy
safe
kind of
their
income
so this is very very sad i'm not
certainly not going to make fun of the
man for
talking like a stroke victim because he
is a stroke victim and he doesn't want
to acknowledge that on the campaign
trail because right now he's the
democrat nominee this is his shot to
make it to the u.s senate and so he
obviously should be in at some kind of
rehabilitation facility working on
getting his body back in motion and
getting his speech back but he can't do
that because he's on the campaign trail
this is it this is the election and so
they're going to prop him up for a
couple of minutes at a time and they're
going gonna try to minimize the
political damage of the fact that the
man cannot speak
and then they're just gonna try to use
the the weight of the democrat
establishment to force him into
washington dc and maybe then he will
recover and maybe he won't recover but
it doesn't really matter because either
way even if the guy were in perfect
health he just would have been a rubber
stamp for the democrats this guy is a
radical radical leftist he said if he
had a magic wand the first thing he
would do in politics would be to let all
of the murderers out of prison
he said the the not he wouldn't cure
childhood cancer he wouldn't solve world
hunger no no the first thing he would do
is let murderers out of prison and so
he was always going to be a a rubber
stamp for the the establishment an
avatar for the establishment all he can
talk about now
is this kind of silly stuff about his
identity i live across the street from a
union hall
i we're gonna support the unions
we're i'm pro-worker
what have you done what have you done
what is your record reminds me of ronald
reagan when he was debating jimmy carter
running in 1980
and jimmy jimmy carter peanut farmer
from georgia talking about all these
pond sky high falutin sort of
understandings about ourselves and who
we are as americans and ronald reagan
kills him with one line he says here's
the question are you better off now than
you were four years ago
that's all i'm going to ask well he did
it in a cool reagan way well are you
better off now than you than you were
four years ago and the question cut like
a hot knife through butter because
people looked around they said no i'm
not better off i'm not better off under
democrat
rule these democrats who are
fearmongering and saying that the sky is
going to fall if the republicans take
over kind of feels like the sky is
falling in on me now and you look today
40-year high inflation you've got an
economy that's in shambles you've got
the first major war in europe in 70
years caused in large part by joe biden
even according to the ukrainian
president by vladimir zelinski you've
got three million immigrants coming into
this country every single year this two
million illegal immigrants pouring
across the southern border it's just
you are not better off now
than you were some years ago and if you
say it you're a threat to democracy
according to the libs hello m'lords
hello my ladies go to established titles
dot com
slash knowles you have to do it this is
your opportunity to earn the title of
lord or lady and gain the respect you
deserve all you need is a one square
foot plot of land in scotland
established titles can make it happen
it's a project based on an historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lads for lords and ladies
in english in your title pack you will
be bestowed with at least one square
foot of dedicated land on a private
estate in edelston scotland
plus an official certificate with a
crest your certificate features a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land title packs
from established titles are a fun and
unique gift for any occasion there are
even couple packs because you don't want
to be a lord and then your wife isn't a
lady or vice versa so you can you can
get that for the special someone in your
life with your certificate you can
officially add the prefix of lord or
lady to your credit cards your plane
tickets even your dating profiles plus
established titles commits to preserving
the woodlands not only in scotland but
around the world they have partnerships
with global charities such as one tree
planted and trees for the future to help
with our aforestation efforts and
for every order they receive a tree is
planted
do it right now establish titles told me
that the first 200 people purchasing a
title pack using my exclusive link will
receive a plot within a few walking
minutes of mine that's right so we can
be lards and ladies together depending
on how many of you want to become a lard
our lady we can build our own kingdom
established titles is running a massive
sale right now plus if you use my code
knowledge you get an additional 10 off
go to establishtitles.com
to get your gift now and help support
the channel i'm so glad that you liked
that clip now if you want to get more
clips more notifications you got to ring
the bell subscribe take us from 1
million subscribers to 1 billion that's
right we can do it we need your help
ring that bell we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]